John where are you I'm gonna guess it
Dan hey nobody good good how's the
weather
oh it's been great last night we had a
pretty much about a half inch of rain
but other than that it's beautiful
sunshiny about 60 degrees this morning
how's your game oh it's ok don't be a
rookie again here virtually today just
wanna see occur so after this week I'll
be going on Arkansas getting ready for
it so you turn 50 at the end of the
month April 28th oh boy
what kind of party is that 50th going to
be I don't know yet cuz I'm gonna do
something down in Dallas
I haven't we haven't figured it out yet
unless somebody's gonna do something
that I don't know about but other than
that really don't have much plans for it
if I told you 25 years ago that you
would be headed to the Senior Tour what
would you say what would you think well
I never thought you'd ask me I you know
I can't believe you didn't say I can't
believe you made it to almost
that was my follow up John are you
surprised you reach 50 yeah I know why
some you know a little lot of close
calls but yeah hey I know there's a few
people in the world that can say that
though when you I mean how excited are
you to play on the Senior Tour and are
you done with the the regular tour no no
I'll play in any PGA tournament I can
still get in I mean I'm excited about
the Champions Tour to be able to get a
schedule again and play a lot of golf
and you know go into the British Open
other PGA Championships or PGA servants
that I might get in like being ready
golf ready
no these last few years it's been one
tournament three weeks off one time at
three weeks off it's been tough we had
Jack Nicklaus on yesterday and your
final round of the 1991 PGA Championship
now you've got a note in your locker
from Jack
yeah I mean you know I've learned how to
play the game because exact necklace
um golf lesson T taught me everything I
need to know about how the grip and
everything and then met jack in 1989 he
was talking to mr. Chohan over the
square-root deals and and Sunday morning
I had a note from him on my locker so go
get him John Jack Nicklaus
got it framed in my house and everything
oh that's cool I asked Jack about 1986
with his putter and you know he says
it's probably worth between 4 and 5
million dollars but he doesn't know
where it is do you have he said he said
his kids may have given it away not
knowing that it was dad's putter from
1986 no no I'm sure he's got that safe
somewhere for one of us one of his kids
are for the Nicklaus family
I know as players we tend to not get rid
of putters and unless we donate him to
museums and stuff like that but I
guarantee that bet he's got it no no he
said he goes he got the one back from
that he used it Baltus role I think but
he can't find this one and and he says
it's probably worth between four and
five million dollars and somebody's
probably got it in their you know their
bag in the garage somewhere you never
know they could the greatest thing about
that putter was is I could I could have
used that for a driver and a putter do
you have your ear clubs from your two
majors I have donated my pink set to the
University of Arkansas with the driver
and stuff and then I just got back I had
my British Open set a wicked stick which
was bid been sold so they were gracious
enough to give me all that all those
clubs back talking to John Daly joining
us from Augusta are you uh are you
parked on Washington right now with the
RV can people stop buying volume yeah
come get some wings at Hooters or some
cold beer and come buy some product for
me we're having a good time here dance
it's been great it's been a wonderful
week to what has been absolutely perfect
I could say
for last night if you were playing
though is this ideal weather cuz some
guy said hey you want to bring in the
wind I'm fine with that the wind doesn't
bother me just it the only the only
person that bothers me is me who do you
who do you like to win
well my dark horse is with this week is
Danny Willett I still think you're gonna
see the cream of the crop I think it's
gonna be a Jason de Nicola I never count
fill out and never count bye-bye I'll
watch out for like guys like scott
Piercy and Danny Willett they both play
really good on fast fast greens how
would you compare speed seer not to not
to Tigers best year but it was it tiger
like early tiger like I kind of put the
thing in my doing is he's kind of doing
what I did man he's playing
I honestly think he's playing Jimmy
leaks in a row I mean I mean god bless
him he's so good but mentally I don't
care what you say when you play five six
seven eight in a row I think he needs to
kind of go between what I did when I was
successful and what Tiger did when he
was successful you know Tiger you know
he had to he had to get he had to find
another tournament just to get his 15 in
that 10-year period you know what I mean
he's winning all those tournaments and
Jordan traveling all over the world like
I did and stuff I'm telling you right
now it takes a toll on him and my only
advice that kid as great as he is I love
him to death
I would I would hold the reins back just
a little bit and not play too many
tournaments like he's doing yeah he went
overseas to start the year and and he
came back it seemed like it took a toll
on him well he won kapalua I mean you
know he won that and everybody's got the
hopes up he's gonna keep winning and
winning but I don't care how young you
are you know it'd be like the NFL
football players playing three games a
week it would kill them you know it's
just it just can't happen you've got it
you've got to take some time to yourself
and that's the only thing fuzzy teller
always told me hey man you're just
playing too much Goff you got to get
away from it a little bit Tiger after 40
here you are turning 50 Tigers got 10
years before he goes to the Senior Tour
feve and does that
what can you expect here Jack Nicklaus
won two majors at age 40
course he won the Masters at 46 but he
was a lot healthier than Tiger is what
do you expect
Tiger after 40 I still believe in Tiger
he's I love his golf game I love what
he's done for the game of golf I
honestly believe that Tiger Woods can
still win I mean Jack Nicklaus did it at
46 and you know I I just I still believe
in him I don't think you can count him
out I'm just thinking I'm looking at all
these guys that you know I'm looking at
Laurie McEvoy putting 250 pounds and
weight on his shoulders I'm just telling
him he said these guys are not getting
hurt from playing is much golf for
getting heard from working out they just
need to be real careful that's to me
that's what I feel like Tiger did he
worked out so hard that of all the balls
we hit anyway and then you put any put
all these weights in their policy
believe that Tiger got hurt from working
out so much yeah if you look at the old
footage of him I mean he's rail-thin
then all of a sudden you know he he
wanted to look like a Navy SEAL yeah I
mean it's just it's just you know I mean
it's unbelievable I mean I'm not saying
cuz I don't work out I'm just saying I
think some of these guys are just push
themselves too hard I'd rather hit an
extra fifty golf balls with 60 golf
balls and just put a waiting arm you
know what's the hole that you would want
to play today at Augusta if you only got
one hole to play one hole to play yeah
uh probably I just my favorite hole up
this probably I love number six I love I
love I love five and six I just I just
think they're the holes that can kind of
make a break in an early rounds are you
allowed to smoke on the course when you
play yeah at Augusta
yeah oh I didn't know I didn't fire up a
heater there I thought that they were
pretty particular about what you're
allowed to do no I don't know I hadn't
played this in so six but I did I never
do one on the ground I always made sure
I put it in my bag cocaine or a cup or
something and I you know I never do it
on the ground but yeah they don't smoke
when's the last time you played Augusta
honey it was 2006 okay I thought you
said when you were six and I was gonna
go
what waiting I remember you playing at
Augusta so 2006 so 2006 so 10 years is
have passed by you bloody either yeah
either 2005 or 2006 my memories kind of
gone there you know but John you made it
to 50 almost not yet
I had the under I had the under on on
you getting to 50 so uh hello everybody
so people want to stop by the Arby's
there say hello to John are you at the
the Hooters parking lot or right by it
where I'm right in the front door we got
our new rock bottom golf my new grip and
rip it line we had all my lion stuff and
we've got so much stuff it's just been
going great we're having a good time
awesome
can we get a picture from inside the RV
can you take a picture and send it to
Fritzi yeah I'll do that but listen once
you come here next year to see your
radio show it's right here on the bus
we'll do it right here at the Hooters
whoo right huh come on I think yeah I
think it's something we get another year
we need to talk about it but I can't but
I can't go out at night though with you
you don't have to just sit right here we
don't have to more dangerous John I got
to wake up to do a show in the morning
good or bad I feel all right let me talk
to my people and I'll let you know yeah
I think it'd be fun anyway she came for
two or three days to do it it'd be cool
all right oh don't talk to some of my
people yeah we're gonna get you selling
some stuff to no workit guy nice do what
to see what the hard-working people are
doing Dan well good luck in the next
couple of weeks get in 250 and have fun
down there behave thanks good to talk to
you bud all right that's John Daly the
Dan Patrick show we
on audience